given all her recent media appearances
it's pretty clear that Obama's former
national security adviser Susan Rice is
seriously gunning to be Joe Biden's
number two now yesterday on Meet the
Press she revealed that sheepish of her
political ambitions well she did so when
she commented on what has largely turned
out to be a very murky story concerning
Russian bounties on American soldiers in
Afghanistan this is not the time to be
handing Putin an olive branch we have a
president who is doing our arch
adversaries bidding it would seem and
he's surrounded by sycophants and
weaklings who aren't doing their jobs
who don't have the confidence in
themselves and in the mission that
they're there to carry out to bring the
president the tough messages he needs to
hear now one of the targets of that
smear Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
joins me exclusively now mr. secretary
great to see you now yeah I know you
feel that Rice's remarks show a lack of
restraint that our country can't afford
to have back in the White House explain
all that Laura thanks for having me on
to here ambassador rice talk that way is
just crazy yet you know she has a
history of going on setting the shows
and lying you'll all remember that back
in 2012 she won on five Sunday shows and
ambassador Chris Stevens Sean Smith Glen
Doherty and Tyrone woods had all
perished under her administration's
watch in Benghazi Libya she went on and
made up a story about a video in a
protest when she knew full well that
this was a terror attack she did so
because was politically convenient to
say that it's a it's the worst kind of
behavior from a national security leader
and and as for her comments about Russia
it was on the Obama watch under the
Susan Rice watch under Vice President
Biden's watch that Ukraine had one fifth
of its real estate taken by Vladimir
Putin with virtually no response it was
under her watch that Syria was handed
over to the Russians as a result of a
redline that Obama had drawn in the
Sabbath and refused to enforce and
you'll recall too when it comes to
American soldiers taking care of what
she suggests this administration didn't
do but does always it was her
administration that was underwriting the
Iranian regime while it was killing
American soldiers in the Middle East
that was an administration that didn't
care about our soldiers sailors airmen
and Marines and certainly didn't act
away that was securing the American
national interest now mr. secretary we
don't have to play the soundbite but
John Bolton essentially in his
never-ending media tour for his book he
said it's inconceivable that the
president wouldn't have been briefed on
this report about Russia your response
to his continued push against the
administration on these matters of
national security yeah I don't want to
go back and forth with John Bolton other
than to say much of what he had in his
book and the number of the things he has
said in the aftermath of that haven't
proven to be true he he was there he saw
that this administration worked hard to
make sure the President had all the
information he needed to make good sound
national security decisions and with
respect to this particular issue in
Afghanistan I can assure every one of
your viewers that this administration
acted in a way to protect every American
who was serving in Afghanistan we have
we have fought the Taliban harder than
the previous administration ever dreamed
about fighting them and now President
Trump is going to protect our soldiers
by working to get a peace and
reconciliation deal that allows them to
come home mr. secretary your thoughts on
these former bush staffers this is kind
of what they did when Trump was running
the pheno in 2016 but all these former
bush staffers coming out and saying
we're gonna support Joe Biden what what
about that and what does that reveal
about their alliances the Alliance's
they'll make in order to defeat Donald
Trump it's it's sad this is an
administration that has executed its
national security function in a way that
every American can be proud of whether
it was striking costumes Soleimani or
the remarkable work we did to take down
the entire Caliphate in Syria and
terrorism the work we've done to put
pressure on Iran to watch these former
officials now suggest that somehow
former Vice President Biden is going to
be the right outcome to protect
Americans is just silly what will their
China policy look like from what you
know now with what Biden believes is the
real threat to the United States and the
culture wars that are well what could we
expect as Americans as a policy toward
China if that likelihood would come to
pass I think we know because we have
eight years of history with a President
Obama and Vice President Biden's China
policy and they did nothing whether it
was on the important issues were facing
today on human rights whether that's in
Tibet or Hong Kong or in the western
part where we are being forced to
conduct abortions and forced
sterilizations they did nothing whether
it was a Taiwan where they refused to do
the right thing or even protecting
Americans from predatory economic
activity costing Americans thousands and
hundreds of thousands of jobs here in
the United States we know what the
obama-biden administration did with
respect to China the kowtow it appeased
turned the other cheek and it left
America in a weaker position as a direct
result of that failure to lead now
speaking of which I know you've probably
seen this but China's eradicating a
freedom in Hong Kong you warned of this
for years and The Wall Street Journal
reports that Chinese law now requires
Hong Kong authorities to strengthen
regulation of the media and the internet
and empowers Beijing to deploy state
security agencies to establish a bureau
overseeing national security in Hong
Kong and now they're not ruling out mr.
secretary China is not blocking Hong
Kong citizens from leaving for the UK
because the UK says you want to come
back and live here come here so what's
our response going to be would we
welcome in welcomed the Hong Kongers
into the United States if China is
continues along this path which they
most certainly will yellow it's almost
certain they're going to continue on
this path to your point a few weeks back
now President Trump made clear that
Hong Kong was no longer autonomous I
certified in the same and we can see
this is gonna end up just being another
communist run city it's unfortunate Hong
Kong was such a special place where
there were all the freedoms that the
people of Hong Kong were promised by the
Chinese Communist Party it's it's much
like the promise they made to tell us
the truth about where the coronavirus
came from we know it started in Wuhan we
know it came from China and yet they
covered it up for an awfully long time
it's the same kinds of broken promises
that'll lead the United States to take
the right response with respect to Hong
Kong's new national security law we've
already begun the process of revoking
visas for people who made these
decisions and there will be a series of
actions that the administration will
take we'd love to preserve the freedom
in hong kong but if we can't we're gonna
hold Chinese Communist Party accountable
and finally mr. secretary the huge
Chinese app tik-tok has about 30 million
users in the United States but it's been
banned now by India in Australia is
considering the same action saying that
tik-tok was full of mass surveillance
and propaganda and also that the app had
the ability to feed information straight
to Beijing so kind of obvious question
if all that's the case shouldn't we be
considering right now tonight a ban on
Chinese social media apps especially
tik-tok law your viewers should know
we're taking this very seriously we're
certainly looking at it we've worked on
this very issue for a long time whether
it was the problems of having huawei
technology in your infrastructure we've
gone all over the world and we're making
real progress getting that out we had
declared ZTE a danger to American
national security one of those things
with respect to Chinese apps on people's
cell phones I can assure you the United
States will get this one right to Laura
I don't want to get out I don't want to
get in front of the president but it's
something we're looking at would you
recommend that people download that up
on their phones tonight tomorrow anytime
currently only if you want your private
information in the hands of the Chinese
Communist Party mr. secretary it's great
to see you as always tonight thank you
lord